[Music]
okay welcome i'm emily conover senior
physics writer for science news
in honor of the 100th anniversary of our
publication we are interviewing some
leaders in science on some big questions
i am delighted to be tackling the topic
of black holes with dr andrea guess an
astrophysicist at ucla and notably a
winner of the 2020 nobel prize in
physics
for her work that unveiled the
supermassive black hole at the center of
our home galaxy the milky way
thanks so much for speaking with me dr
guz oh it's a pleasure to be here
so um
i think it's it's fair to say that black
holes are having a moment right now um
on top of your own research and the
nobel prize
we have uh the gravitational wave
observatories which in 2015 first
spotted black hole two black holes
spiraling together and merging we have
the first image of a black hole
silhouette from the event horizon
telescope in 2019 and lots of other too
many exciting results to mention so i
think it's really fitting that we're
talking about this topic today and right
now um
and i thought maybe to start uh for our
viewers who might be less familiar with
black holes or might only know them from
science fiction movies um can you start
by just defining what a black hole is
sure black holes are remarkably simple
given the fact that they really push our
understanding of physics forward
or challenge our understanding of
physics so a black hole
is very simply a region of space
where the pull of gravity is so intense
that nothing can escape it not even
light
you can also think of it just
as an object whose mass is confined to
zero
volume and so the idea of density which
is mass divided by volume
that goes to infinity and that's like
the big giant red arrow that says you
don't have your description of physics
correct right here
yeah and that's sort of where all the
weird puzzles come in right
um and your work in particular you focus
on uh super massive black holes one
super massive black hole in particular
um can you talk a little bit about the
distinction between these sort of super
massive giant guys and those the smaller
black holes
i mean in astrophysics we think of two
classes of black holes and in fact the
fact these two classes nicely
demonstrate the two ways in which
science is often done so the first ones
that were recognized or understood are
what we call the stellar mass black
holes and they're the outcome of how
stars that start off their life as very
massive stars with more than 30 times
the mass of the sun are expected to end
up so predicted by theory and
demonstrated beautifully observationally
with the gravitational wave uh detectors
um
the supermassive black holes are much
more massive as the name suggests so
rather than being on order of 10 times
the mass of the sun
they're more like a million to a billion
times the mass of the sun
and
we think that they reside at the center
of galaxies so that each galaxy is
thought to form with one central
supermassive black hole so these were
found observationally and now we're on
the hunt to understand theoretically um
how they how they formed
one thing you know about both types of
black holes they're sort of this
nexus of these lots of these really big
questions in physics and astronomy and
they cover sort of a variety of
different sort of subfields right so you
have fundamental tests of general
relativity which is einstein's theory of
gravity
questions about how galaxies form you
know everything in between right so i
i'm i'm curious what you think what is
the reason that black holes in general
are such fruitful
grounds for research on such a variety
of
topics oh that's an interesting question
um
i mean in the case
of fundamental physics which really
crosses both the stellar mass black
holes and the supermassive black holes
you really have very fundamental
questions about how our universe works
we only have four
known forces and gravity is one it's the
one we're most familiar with in terms of
our intuition here on earth you throw a
ball up it comes back down and yet it's
actually the least tested of the four
forces
um so gram so black holes um
provide this avenue for furthering our
understanding of fundamental physics and
in particular
our our
inability at the moment to bring
together the two fields of quantum
mechanics which is the study of things
that are very small together with a
field of um general relativity which is
our just best description of how gravity
works
in the case of supermassive black holes
these things reside at the center of
galaxies where you have um
extreme environments in many many
different ways i mean not only is the
gravitational field extreme because of
the black hole itself but the the
centers of galaxies are extreme in many
other um aspects such as the stellar
density so people often refer to the the
center of galaxies as like the urban hub
it's like you know the center of new
york city and we're out in the half you
know we're halfway out in the galaxy so
we're out in the column suburbs
um
but other
almost any way you can describe a galaxy
becomes more extreme um the magnetic
fields the winds just the activity in
general is really extreme so it means
that you have an opportunity to
understand
the physical processes that are
associated with multiple aspects of a
galaxy in the extreme environment of
this of the center of galaxies so in the
case of the supermassive black holes you
get that extra layer of trying to
understand not only the formation and
evolution of these galaxies which we
think the black hole plays a central
role in but just physics
sort of physics of the extremes
yeah that's great i know physicists
always love to look at the most extreme
example and use that to test their
understanding
so i think black holes are definitely a
good example of that
um
great so i'm i'm curious if you could
tell us um your sort of scientific
origin story so what was it that
originally drew you into this topic or
how did you
get started uh with your fascination
with black holes
origin stories are always complicated
astrophysically or otherwise um so mine
i can um i can tell you a narrative that
will make sense but it wasn't actually
as clean as the narrative which i'll
also share so um the family lure is that
when i was four years old and i do
remember this the first moon landing was
happening um so i got excited about
thinking about the universe
certainly
started to stay up late at night
wondering worrying about you know the
enormity the time scales the boundary
um and the family legend is i wanted to
i announced that i wanted to be the
first woman on the moon
i mean today i joke you know the job's
still open
but i certainly got more interested in
pursuing astrophysics from the ground
but at the same time i also wanted to be
a ballerina as little kids are want to
do they have multiple ideas about or
ways of of thinking about their future
so um
while i got exposed to it early on and
was fascinated by it i wasn't singular
or certain
in my path forward
but what i
do remember and i think really um uh
connects is that i've always been
interested in pro solving problems so uh
ultimately my interest in dance got into
choreography which is basically a
problem-solving exercise of how do you
put this you know this dance story
together
um and i became very good at math um so
i actually went off to college wanting
to be a math major uh
and uh soon discovered it was much more
esoteric than i thought um
and and at that point was was quite
interested in black holes so i switched
to physics as a as a
as
maybe more an experimental approach as
opposed to a theoretical approach to to
black holes
right um so when you were starting your
work um
what can you describe for us what was
sort of the
scientific attitude towards black holes
what you know were people confident that
they
existed or was there still some question
and then how did your work sort of move
that um forward
yeah so when i started this project
there was definitely the idea or the
notion
that um supermassive black holes might
exist at the center of galaxies and in
particular
um the state of the field was that um
there's a small class where
about ten percent of all galaxies have
an unusually um an unusual amount of
energy coming out from their centers
they're called active galactic nuclei i
mean their name really says it all their
nuclei or their centers are very active
and it was hypothesized that what was
driving all this activity um was a
supermassive black hole at the center so
that that would be the central engine
and roughly
um
at that same time people were asking
um
could it possibly be true that all
galaxies harbor supermassive black holes
and in the case of normal galaxies
these are black holes that are basically
on a diet are lacking
material falling onto the black hole
which is how we thought the active
galactic nuclei were being powered but
in our own case in our case of our own
milky way the idea you know our galaxy
is a ordinary garden-variety galaxy
nothing special about us
um
the idea there is that the there was
there's very little gas at the center
and so perhaps this is a black hole that
was simply starved so um that really
offered i mean that's what also
introduced the idea that the the milky
way is a great place to ask this because
it's the closest example
of a supermassive black hole that we'll
ever have to study
the next closest one is a hundred times
further away
now while there was that idea there were
also some counter arguments to the um
the idea that our galaxy could harbor a
supermassive black hole
um or just that all galaxies had
supermassive black holes
and that was that there were very young
stars um seen in the in the proximity
not as close as we ended up looking but
out at further distances so already the
existence of these young stars
gave some trouble to the notion that
there was a black hole there because
black holes produce these very strong
tidal forces so the the
idea that gravity depends on distance so
that the the pull on one side of an
object is greater than the pull on the
other side of the object so much so that
it just distorts or pulls apart the
object itself and stars baby stars start
off with as very fragile clouds of gas
and dust
so there was this problem already that
uh people said well look there's not
enough gas or dense enough gas to
overcome this problem so that's an
argument against the black hole so
that's really where the argument was in
the early 90s when we jumped in
you know a nice scenario for why they
should be there and an argument against
them um so that was really the state
of the field
although i should mention one other
thing which is that we did know that
there was an unusual radio source at the
middle
its name is sagittarius a star
so sagittarius because uh it's the
constellation of sagittarius so if you
look up at night and you look for the
constellation of the the teacup it pours
into the center of the galaxy so that's
where that's how you can find the center
of the galaxy if you're out camping
and
a because it was the brightest radio
source and star because people were
trying to be very clever they were um
they were borrowing did uh notation from
nuclear physics where the asterisks
meant excited state so they were seeing
gas that didn't look like a star so it
was ass jay's really not a star so it's
one of those um names that's uh
so we really should say sanjay's not a
star
so they thought it was like a low
very very very very very very faint um
equivalent of the active galactic nuclei
centers
right
um
so then
you come in and start looking at the
these stars that are very close to the
uh you know sad j star which you know at
that point in time was not known whether
it was a supermassive black hole or not
um how did were you able to reveal that
in fact that that is what what we were
seeing there
so we um the idea of the work that we
did was um
that stars that are
very close should provide the most
direct evidence for a supermassive black
hole through their emotions so if you
can discover stars that are there and
track their motion so basically watch
their orbits these stars should orbit
the center of the galaxy for the same
reason that planets orbit the sun
so it's just gravity and each orbit
tells you how much mass is inside its
orbit and then the
size of the scale of that orbit tells
you the the region that you can find the
mass to so the proof of the black hole
is lots of mass inside a very small
volume
or radius
and in fact you'd like to get inside the
short shield radius because that's the
point at which gravity overcomes all
other known forces and forces that mass
to become the infinitesimally small
object that we know as of as a black
hole um so
you want to see stars as close to the
center of the galaxy so the first
challenge was can we can we find them
can we discover them
and since you want to get close you you
need to go to wavelengths where you can
see the starlight so radio wavelengths
you don't you don't see much light from
that from the stars it's mostly
dominated by the gas
so we went to the infrared
you can go to the optical or the
infrared to see
starlight but at the center of the
galaxy there's lots of get there's lots
of dust between us and the center of the
galaxy
and that dust is very good at absorbing
optical light what our eye detects so
it's basically invisible at optical
wavelengths but if you go to the
infrared you can see that's that
starlight so that's why all our work has
been done in the infrared
next you want to go to a big telescope
the larger your telescope the
the
better the angular resolution so you
want to see stars that are as close as
possible so it's really important that
you get to high angular resolution
so the larger the telescope in principle
the smaller the scale that you can
actually see
and the largest telescope in the world
they can see infrared light right now is
the keck telescope this is out in hawaii
but it's on the ground and so you have
to contend with the atmosphere so the
next challenge is you have to beat the
atmosphere and so that's what we've done
a lot of work on is trying to figure out
how to beat the atmosphere so that you
can actually
see these stars and track their emotions
yeah
um i have to say that the the
videos that you've made of showing this
data over decades of these stars moving
around the supermassive black hole they
are so fascinating to watch um i
just love kind of marveling at the fact
that we can even see these stars and
measure them moving around this you know
extremely massive black hole
um it blows me away every time so i'm
just curious when did you when were you
first able to to see that and and you
know what was the feeling that you had
when you were first able to do that
oh gosh um so this actually goes back to
when i first joined the faculty at ucla
um that was in 1994. so i got i i joined
the faculty because i really wanted to
do this experiment i wanted access to
the keck telescope keck is co-owned by
the university of california in caltech
so this to me was my dream job so i put
my very first proposal in in 1994 and it
was turned down
so it was turned down because
people hadn't done this diffraction
limited imaging at keck yet so um
they weren't there you know there was a
lot of skepticism about whether or not
keck which is a segmented telescope
could actually achieve diffraction
limited uh resolution in spite of the
fact that it was designed to do so so it
took us a year to convince people that
our approach would work
um but so we started in 1995 as a result
um
so the first thing we needed to do was
demonstrate that the technique would
work and in 90 i guess we actually did
that in 94. we we just
had to prove that the technique would
work and then in 95 we actually saw the
images um so you could you could prove
that they could work this this business
works at the center of the galaxy so
that was really exciting in 95
but you haven't seen the motion yet so
the original
approach was just to see how things move
on the plane of the sky so you need two
images so we did that in 96 if two
points two points determine a line and
oh my goodness i cannot tell you how
exciting it was in 1996 to get that
second image and of course
um
you know there are lots of challenges
along the way including the first night
in 96 was weathered out the second night
i think
we had instrument problems and it was
the third time we um
went in and actually got that got the
data so
there's nothing like a little bit of um
obstacle to make the success even
sweeter
we didn't publish until 97 because we
actually wanted three points to make
sure we understood um uh how well we
were doing because of course there are
lots of challenges associated with
making these measurements so it was 97
that we submitted our first first paper
on doing this
i'll say actually i can say a little bit
more about that phase which was also
interesting really fun because we always
thought we were going to do a three-year
experiment uh wow um so the original
idea was just get the velocities because
you can prove statistically
um uh you can use ensemble averages um
or velocity dispersions rather to get
the enclosed mass but at that point
people were pushing back there was a lot
of skepticism that it wasn't actually a
black hole and the particle physicists
got into the act at this point and
started suggesting that there were other
kinds of objects it could be
and in particular the fermi the idea
that it could be a fermion ball
so these are um objects that are i guess
they're like neutron stars so rather
than being a pure object of neutrons
these are um uh more primitive uh
particles which means that it's more
compact
and there were also suggestions that
these objects the the fast-moving stars
that we were seeing really close in um
weren't actually bound to the center of
the galaxy
it was really fun i guess it was really
fun at this point in the experiment
because people were starting to push
back on the idea that the velocities
that we would we're seeing
were from the black hole
and you can do a freshman physics
calculation that tells you that you
should be soon seeing the accelerations
if this is indeed a black hole so we
just kept going and soon enough the
things started to curve and at that
point you can do some again simple
things um there were three stars that
showed the first accelerations and each
acceleration should point to where the
black hole is because it's a central uh
potential and the central potential
should be radial and even in projection
you should get these vectors that point
to this is where the black hole is and
so all of a sudden you actually can show
to much higher person that the this mass
is associated with that unusual radio
source such a star to
um
very high degree of accuracy and again
pushes you to um
to the next level because at that point
you know that the orbit should only be
on order of 10 years long
we've been going for five years what's
another five years and at that point
um it was clear that we should continue
and people at that even at that point
were
starting to anticipate the power of
these orbits that these orbits and it
could show you that not only that there
was a black hole
but could introduce new ways of testing
einstein's
theories of general relativity so i i
have to say that that paper the
acceleration paper which came out in
2000
was really a transformative moment i
think it's that's at the point that we
really understood how much
how much science could come from um this
sort of work um
it was really it was really uh
it was really an exciting moment
yeah and you're still of course working
on on the same uh area you know the
center of the galaxy today right so um
uh uh
i mean i guess i'm wondering you know do
you uh
do you ever lose interest i mean how do
you how does this keep your attention
for so long you know from the 90s until
now
well what's what's been so fascinating
about this is there's been such
evolution both in terms of the the data
themselves because um you keep you keep
going and of course with the or the game
of orbits time really helps um the power
of these measurements um increases
dramatically with time
but along the way we've also
had the
benefit of advances in technology so
after the first decade we moved from a
very simple approach of speckle imaging
which only allowed us to take images at
a single wavelength and that were not
very deep to adaptive optics which was a
much more powerful technique and opened
up
new kinds of measurements
and the most important was our ability
to get spectroscopy which gave us motion
along the third dimension along our line
of sight but also told us what kind of
stars we were looking at
which revealed a host of new
questions astrophysical questions
and that along with being able to take
images at different wavelengths just
opened up many new questions so i think
that's part of what's been so
fascinating or captivating about this
project is
the continual
um
opportunities to go in new directions so
while it seems like we've been doing the
same thing all the time or for a long
time two
more than two decades in fact the kinds
of questions that have been pursued have
changed
quite dramatically over time
right yeah going from you know is there
a supermassive black hole there at all
to can we test you know does general
relativity apply near the supermassive
black hole and and so on right
um
yeah today we're looking at black hole
accretion physics we're looking at tidal
interactions we're looking at star
formation in extreme environments
we're looking at dynamical
interactions i mean
um among other things uh it's it and of
course the the the new testament of gr
really exciting um and now we're on the
hunt for dark matter so
it's um
it's been
it's been an incredibly rich um
adventure
well it's interesting to me because
i think naively
you might expect that black holes would
be sort of a dead end because they're
black and you can't
see inside them so you don't know what's
going on right
um but we've had so many interesting
observations right to reveal more
details of these objects
in all these different inventive ways
right
so i'm curious if you have any thoughts
about um
how we've been able to make so much
progress and do you think that people
you know when black holes first uh
appeared in physicists minds do you
think people expected that we'd be able
to understand them as well as we do now
well that's an interesting question um
about what what people understood i mean
i think scientists are incredibly
optimistic um in general uh
i think
um
there's always an unders i mean i think
for a long time there's an understanding
that technology is always going to drive
your understanding of science further
um
so who knows i mean it's really it's uh
it's i'm sure they didn't imagine where
we are today i mean we couldn't we
didn't even imagine where we were today
when we started this experiment so
you know half a century ago um
but that's that's one of the wonderful
things about science is it evolves so
quickly i mean
especially in astrophysics i mean if we
think about how far our understanding of
the universe and all the phenomena that
are
in it um have evolved uh it's it's
rather remarkable
yeah
it seems to be one of those one of those
situations where um
black holes are just so fascinating to
physicists that the throw have
everything every technology every tool
that might be useful at understanding
them and uh then we get some really cool
science out of that so
well as you mentioned
uh earlier um
you know when you were doing your
measurements and when you're beginning
to do these measurements no one had ever
done them before right um
i'm curious if you ever felt like you
were on the wrong track or you worried
that you might not succeed what was what
was that like for you
oh gosh yes i mean i wish quite frankly
i wish i had kept a diary through this
whole experiment
because it's been
i guess today 27 years of
lots of highs and lows and uncertainty
and delight
all along the way
and
there are definitely ebbs and flows
throughout this whole
project
i think
there was a time
right before adaptive optics came online
and we were still in the speckle mode
where that wasn't you know it was in
some sense it's like we were getting to
the limit of the return for speckle
imaging and i think that was
um that was an interesting lull
we did know adaptive optics was was um
uh was coming and um you know we were we
were pushing forward on that front but
um
you know it's always scary before a new
technology actually becomes
scientifically productive
is it actually going to deliver
the promise
and i've been working with adaptive
optics for
15 years before it became scientifically
productive so um you know you're never
sure so i think that was one of the
really exciting things about the keck
system
is that unlike a lot of earlier systems
it it really
was well designed in terms of doing
something that was technically robust
and scientifically mature rather than
being just another
step in terms of technology development
it became scientifically productive
you touched on this quickly earlier but
i i wanted to
give you a chance to go into a little
more detail about um some of the new
questions that your research has opened
up and and what uh big puzzles kind of
weight that that you're looking at
oh there's so many i mean i i love
working with new technologies because
new technologies give you this very
different view on the universe and often
you're quite surprised when you look at
something in a new and different way
so some of the first um problems that
we're still pursuing
um actually hark back to the original
questioning about supermassive black
holes from the young stars
so the closest some of the closest stars
that we've discovered to the
supermassive black hole are actually
young
so
this
exaggerates some of the early concerns
or the the
the tension between the existence of a
supermassive black hole and the
existence of young stars
so the densities that you need
to overcome the tidal forces from a
black hole scale as your distance cubed
so if you bring
your young stars that you've discovered
from being quite farther far away to
where we are today
the densities required
are roughly 10 to the eighth times
higher that you need to overcome the
tidal forces than are seen today so i
call that the title sorry i call that
the paradox of youth
so understanding how you get young stars
in this extreme environment is a really
intriguing problem
and um
it's it's been super interesting because
people
produced theories for explaining this
from all different angles
it's really um it's inspired a lot of
theoretical thinking
and in three fundamentally different
ways
so one idea is that
these really are young stars
but you form them far away
far away where the tidal forces are
really low so that requires you to think
about
a dynamical process that brings these
young stars in really quickly so you
need some sort of express bus in terms
of physical processes for um
migrating them in very quickly and
that's actually quite difficult to do
and you have to invoke an intermediate
mouse black hole between the
supermassive and the stellar mass black
holes so they may exist but we we have
yet to really um have um
ironclad evidence
so that's a possibility um although a
lot lots of questions another idea is
that maybe these things that we're
seeing as young stars aren't young stars
they're old stars um which are
masquerading as youth
and the idea there is that old stars
have had lots of time to form someplace
else and migrate in so that's certainly
a possibility
and then the third possibility is that
these are young stars that really formed
where you see them so in situ and that
the gas densities when they were being
formed was much higher you know by the
10 million or sorry 100 million times
higher than we see today
and um as we kept making our
measurements of orbits um there was
another there was an important signature
that evolved for these young stars that
were
distributed through this central region
which is roughly half of the young stars
seem to result
reside in a disk so have orbits that all
lined up so in fact it looks a lot like
a
scaled up solar system
and so in fact you can borrow some ideas
from planet formation or the formation
of our own solar system where some of
these planets might have formed out of a
an accretion disk that existed at the
time of formation
and in fact this is the most popular
idea today for explaining the the young
stars at the center of the galaxy is
that our galaxy might have had a very
thick accretion disk a few million years
ago which would not have only would not
which would not only have formed these
young stars but also could have supplied
um
a reservoir of gas to accrete onto the
central black hole making our black hole
seem much more like of an active
galactic nuclei than it does today
suggesting that the whole galaxy was
much more active in its youth than it's
than it is today
another mystery is um
surrounds the old stars the
um
the old stars um as i mentioned before
should be congregated around the black
hole
and should form something called a cusp
but an enhancement of their densities
the local concentration of old stars
should be
great near the supermassive black hole
and in fact we look for that
concentration of light that comes from
that that that that enhancement of the
the the crowding
in other galaxies
but we don't see that in the old stars
we actually see a dearth of old stars at
the center of the galaxy and so that's
been yet another mystery how do you
explain this phenomena that we um think
is um
uh
a prediction of
of having a supermassive black hole at
the center of a galaxy that we rely on
um
and that might have to do with there's
again a couple ways out um
these uh
either
um
something
dynamically perturbed the galaxy in the
recent past so maybe we accreted a
little um a small galaxy that messed up
this local concentration
or these old stars that we can
see were stripped of their outer
atmospheres making them seem faint
and then the last idea is that the cusp
resides in objects that we can't see
this is called the dark cusp problem and
that's that's a
an intriguing idea
um that we're now trying to to sort out
um with the measurements of stellar
orbits because that dark cusp should
actually impact the way these the um the
the stars orbit
so that that is um
a second uh very intriguing idea
the third the third that i'll share and
i'll stop there but there's there's
countless
other directions
is a class of objects that are um
that were not predicted made there were
no predictions for these like unlike the
young and the old where we had clear
predictions um
these are objects that when they come
through close their closest approach
with the black hole they seem to be
tidally distorted which is incredibly
fun
to be able to see things evolve over
time so not only do we see
stars orbiting on a human time scale but
we see these stars
become tidally elongated as they get
near the black hole and then become
compact again
and this is surprising
and this was only with the advances of
the ability to see images and at
different wavelengths at longer
wavelengths
as well as the spectroscopy
and what we think these are are
objects that
merged so most stars are actually formed
as binary stars
if you put a binary star near a black
hole you get a three-body interaction
and that three-body interaction could
cause the binaries to merge
and during that merger process what
happens to the star is it gets bloated
gets really fat about a hundred times
larger than the other stars that we see
the more
the more typical the more anticipated
stars and as that very bloated star goes
by the black hole it's large enough to
experience these tidal interactions and
have the the outer shell affected by um
the black hole
and that's exciting this one i find
super um
intriguing because it may be lighting up
a process that may explain one of the
mysteries associated with the
gravitational wave experiment
so in in ligo in
ligo and virgo they're seeing
um objects that are more massive than
they expected so stellar mass
black holes that are 30 times the mass
of the sun rather than 10 times the mass
of the sun and also at a frequent
occurring at a frequency much higher
than they expected
so most stars are concentrated towards
the center of galaxies and if you think
this three-body interaction is driving
merger effect events and mergers are the
underlying phenomena that you see with
gravitational
waves you may be lighting up a process
that's really important for explaining
um the source of gravitational wave
emission so it's not that we're seeing
black holes merger products but a
process that could be
driving stellar mass black holes that
would also
reside at the center of galaxies so i'm
intrigued by that because it actually
it's it's like a
when you see something you don't expect
in one field providing a maybe a clue to
an unexplained answer in another area
that's like a
unlocking multiple uh secrets so
i'm intrigued by that that third problem
that we see today
yeah that's really fascinating i love
how and this is sort of what i mentioned
at the beginning is that these black
holes the questions you know connect to
so many different other areas of
research
and it's also just so fascinating to me
that we can use this kind of research to
understand what our galaxy was like in
the past uh understand the history of
you know where where we are and you know
what our galaxy was like before
um
just so many big questions it's it's
really fun really interesting
it has been it's been a um it's been
um
an amazing journey to to
to understand what we can understand at
the center of the of the galaxy and i
think we have a lot to be thankful for
in terms of um the the remarkable
progress that's been made
technologically that's opened up our
ability to see this really fascinating
region
well i'm curious what you think um our
future
uh
conception of black holes will be when
will will we have to revise what we
understand about them as we keep
learning more do you think
oh absolutely i mean i think as
scientists we're so
drawn to things that we don't understand
or where or where our models are limited
because those are the places where
there's the most opportunity to advance
our our understanding of physics um so
black holes definitely represent um
the limitation or the frontier of our
knowledge and without a doubt we will be
making progress there's there are so
many new technologies that are emerging
at the moment not only you know with our
ability to see the the stars with
adaptive optics with our ability to see
gravitational waves um through ligo and
virgo
as well as
the event horizon telescope but we have
lisa
to look forward the space-based
gravitational wave detector um which
should open up
the ability to study the supermassive
black holes with gravitational waves
where the the ground-based gravitational
wave experiments are really focused on
or sensitive to the stellar mass
black holes so i think that will be
remarkably
exciting and then in my own area i'm
extremely excited about
the next generation of large
ground-based telescopes so the 30 meter
telescope and um
as it will allow us to see the full
population i mean today we can only see
the brightest stars at the center of the
galaxy and the way i like to explain um
uh what i think the potential is is it
would it's like trying to understand the
economy by only
being able to see the most
the largest transactions which are
big but few and far far between compared
to the smaller
the smaller but more frequent
interactions so same things with the
stars there are lots of um
uh faint stars and very few bright stars
so today we can only see the brightest
stars because they're separated by more
uh larger distances
and the fainter stars become lost in the
confusion
of the uh of the stellar density so at
higher resolution that these these uh
next generation telescopes should afford
us we'll be able to see
beyond the tip of the iceberg and see
those
common everyday stars uh and in
particular we'll be able to see stars
like the sun to understand really the
full range
of activity that resides at the center
of the galaxy well that's very exciting
um it seems like there's a bright future
for for this kind of work i'm curious
what's your
advice to
young people who are fascinated by black
holes and want to go on to study them oh
my advice
to
young people in general is
find out what excites you where your
passion is
and pursue it
anything that's interesting is going to
be hard
interesting and not already done is hard
so um when you have passion uh for
something that uh it'll motivate you to
overcome the inevitable obstacles that
you'll face along the way
andrea thank you so much for talking
with me it's been really fascinating um
and for the viewers uh you can keep up
with the latest discoveries in
astrophysics by visiting us at
sciencenews.org and connecting with us
on social media
thanks for joining us
[Music]